[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg guten Abend schön dass Sie
dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann für
den Sport einen schönen guten Abend auch
von mir schauen wir auf die
Nachrichtenthemen des
Tages schneller und konsequenter
abschieben die Bundesregierung
beschließt ein härteres Vorgehen in der
Migrationspolitik keine Visa mehr für
unmitarbeiter der Streit zwischen Israel
und den Vereinten Nationen
eskaliert und der nächste bitte in den
USA schicken die Republikaner den
mittlerweile vierten Kandidaten ins
Rennen um den Vorsitz des
Repräsentantenhauses die
bundesinnenministerin versprach heute
wir sorgen dafür dass Menschen ohne
Bleibe recht schneller unser Land
verlassen das Kabinett verabschiedete am
Morgen ihren Gesetzentwurf zur Kritik
daran gleich mehr zunächst zeigt Lena
sünderbruch die wichtigsten
Punkte bundesinnenministerin fäser will
ausreisepflichtige schneller abschieben
Polizei und Behörden erhalten nach Ihrem
neuen Gesetzentwurf mehr Befugnisse
Abschiebungen sollen unter bestimmten
Umständen nicht mehr angekündigt werden
die Polizei erhält außerdem mehr Rechte
bei Durchsuchungen sie darf etwa in
einer Gemeinschaftsunterkunft von
geflüchteten auch die Wohnungen Dritter
durchkämmen die Höchstdauer des
ausreisegewahrsams wird verlängert heißt
Menschen dürfen 28 statt 10 Tage unter
haftähnlichen Bedingungen festgehalten
werden das soll verhindern dass sie
untertauchen und ausländische Mitglieder
krimineller Vereinigungen sollen
schneller abgeschoben werden laut
Innenministerium wurden in diesem Jahr
bis Ende September etwa 12000 Menschen
abgeschoben rund
.000 sind aktuell noch
ausreisepflichtig rund Abschiebungen
mehr pro Jahr durch die neuen Regeln
damit rechnet die Bundesregierung es
gibt breite Kritik an dem Gesetzentwurf
von der Opposition sowieso aber auch
Abgeordnete von SPD und Grünen äußern
Bedenken die Maßnahmen würden vor allem
staatliche Härte zeigen möglicherweise
das Grundrecht verletzen aber nicht
spürbar entlasten Bern
Bentin er hatte Ende letzter Woche den
Ton gesetzt wir müssen so Olaf Scholz
endlich im großen Stil diejenigen
abschieben die kein Recht haben in
Deutschland zu bleiben heute billigt das
Kabinett den entsprechenden
Gesetzentwurf der
Innenministerin wir sehen ein Bündel
restriktiver Maßnahmen für mehr und
schnellere Rückführungen vor das ist
notwendig damit wir weiterhin unserer
humanitären Verantwortung für die
Menschen gerecht werden können die wir
vor Krieg und Terror schützen müssen
Kritik am Paket kommt aus der Ampel
selbst Teile der Grünen Zweifeln an der
rechtmäßig auch wenn die Grünen
Kabinettsmitglieder heute zugestimmt
haben wir haben verfassungsrechtliche
Bedenken beim Grundrecht auf Freiheit
Menschen werden ohne Haftgrund
inhaftiert sprich sie sind keine
Straftäter werden aber in Haft genommen
und da sind die Voraussetzung sehr hoch
und müssen sehr hoch bleiben und hier
sehen wir die Gefahr dass der
Rechtsstaat geschliffen wird der
Koalitionspartner FDP
widerspricht das gemeinsame Ziel der
Bundesregierung ist ja dass wir die
irreguläre Migration nach Deutsch
reduzieren und das heißt auch dass wir
sehr klar bei den Abschiebungen sind da
unterstütze ich den Bundeskanzler und
ich erwarte von allen
Regierungsfraktionen dass wir dieses
Paket so durch den Deutschen Bundestag
jetzt schnellst möglich bringen die
Union begrüßt zwar die neuen Pläne
fordert aber eine grundlegendere
Änderung der
Migrationspolitik es reicht nicht nur
etwas bei der Rückführung zu machen
sondern wir brauchen auch eine
tatsächliche substanzielle Begrenzung
der Menschen die hier irregulär nach
Deutschland kommen aus den Bundesländern
die für Abschiebungen zuständig sind
heißt es vor allem müsse es jetzt
Abkommen mit den Herkunftsländern geben
damit Abschiebungen überhaupt praktisch
umsetzbar
werden in Israel ist die Empörung über
die Äußerungen von un Generalsekretär
guterresch weiter groß der israelische
UN-Botschafter forderte guterresch zum
Rücktritt auf und kündigte an dass
Mitarbeiter der Vereinten Nationen keine
Visa mehr bekommen Tim
Krüger un Generalsekretär guteris fühlt
sich missverstanden nach dem eklar
Gestern Heute in New York Versuch einer
Klarstellung ich bin schockiert wegen
der missinterpretation meiner Worte
gestern im Sicherheitsrat von
einigen so als hätte ich die Terrorakte
der Hamas
gerechtfertigt das ist falsch das
Gegenteil ist der
Fall guterisch hatte die Terrorangriffe
der Hamas verurteilt sie aber auch mit
Israels Besatzungspolitik in Verbindung
gebracht Tel Aviv heute Nachmittag die
Worte des un Generalsekretärs gestern
stoßen auf
Unverständnis ich kann nicht begreifen
wie ein Mensch sehen konnte was am 7
Oktober passiert ist und wie man so
etwas sagen
kann ich glaube die Vereinten Nationen
machen weiter wie seit
Jahrzehnten sie wählen eine Seite und
haben kein Verständnis für unsere
Lage der eklar spiegelt die angespannte
Lage im Nahen Osten wieder denn noch
immer ist unklar ob und wann Israel mit
Bodentruppen in den Gazastreifen
einmarschiert und sich der Konflikt
ausweitet das müsse unbedingt verhindert
werden so der französische Präsident
macron und der ägyptische Staatschef als
SIS heute in
Ciro wir haben uns darauf verständigt
dass wir zusammenarbeiten um diese Krise
einz Hilfe zu gewährleisten und seit wie
möglich zu
deeskalieren Israels Luftangriffe auf
den Gazastreifen gehen unterdessen
weiter die Streitkräfte veröffentlichten
heute außerdem Bilder die zeigen sollen
wie sie auf See hamasterroristen daran
hindern erneut nach Israel
einzudringen Michael bwerunge in telaviv
das Wall Street Journal meldet israel
wolle die Bodenoffensive verschieben
können Sie das bestätigen und wie käme
das an im Land
eine offizielle Bestätigung dieser
Meldung gibt es noch nicht allerdings
will sich premier Netanyahu in wenigen
Minuten an die Öffentlichkeit wenden
eine Bestätigung wäre jetzt allerdings
auch keine große Überraschung denn de
facto ist diese Bodenoffensive seit gut
einer Woche verschoben und die
Armeeführung hat gestern auch noch mal
offiziell gesagt dass eine Entscheidung
für den Beginn noch nicht gefallen ist
im Land dürfte eine weitere Verschiebung
mit gemischten Gefühlen auf genommen
werden da sind einmal die Hardliner in
der Armee und auch in der Regierung die
sagen wir müssen so schnell mit wie
möglich mit dieser Bodenoffensive
gewinnen denn mit jedem Tag den dieser
Krieg länger dauert indem es weitere
zivile Opfer in Gaza gibt verlieren wir
die Schlacht um die öffentliche Meinung
in der Welt und dann gibt es aber die
andere Seite vor allem die Angehörigen
der Geiseln und auch ein großer Teil der
Öffentlichkeit der mi ihen bankt die
freuen sich natürlich dass es noch mehr
Zeit gibt für weitere Handlung mit den
Geiseln es heißt man sei gerade in einer
kritischen Phase danke schön für diese
Einschätzung aus telaviv michael bewunge
war das schauen wir noch mal auf die
Situation im
Gazastreifen viele Menschen haben im
Süden Zuflucht gesucht für sie stellt
sich die Frage wo sie in dem dicht
besiedelten Gebiet unterkommen können
ganz in der Nähe zum Grenzort Raffa in
der Stadt hananjunes sind viele
gestrandet ein Team von Euronews hat sie
besucht Pablo Sil erzählt die
Geschichte Ibrahim alaga ist
Palästinenser und ihre die alagas leben
eigentlich in Dublin die Kinder sind in
Irland geboren kurz vor Kriegsbeginn kam
die Familie für einen Besuch nach Gaza
und sitzt nun
fest ich habe einen Anruf von der
irischen Botschaft bekommen sie sagten
dass wir zur Grenze kommen sollen es
gäbe einen Evakuierungsplan für
ausländische Staatsbürger wir sind dahin
hatten einen gefährlichen Weg zur Grenze
aber als wir da waren haben wir einen
zweiten Anruf bekommen wir sollten
wieder zurück nach Hause weil die Grenze
nicht öffnen
werde in den vergangenen Wochen ist das
Elternhaus des doppelstaatlers zu einer
WG für Schutzsuchende geworden als
Ausländer so hoffen sie könnte alaga und
damit das Haus bei der erwarteten
israelischen Bodenoffensive verschont
bleiben viel Platz haben sie nicht gut
70 Menschen leben in vier Zimmern
schlafen müssen sie in
Schichten die ersten zwei Tage waren
schwierig für uns weil wir uns nicht
kannten und jeder Angst hatte und nervös
war aber der älteste und weiseste half
uns zusammenzufinden und unser Geld
zusammenzulegen um die
Lebenshaltungskosten zu
teilen die Wohngemeinschaft war als
Übergangslösung für ein paar Tage
gedacht aber inzwischen haben sie sich
damit arrangiert länger vielleicht noch
viel länger bleiben zu
müssen bundesinnenministerin fer sieht
im Moment keine erhöhte konkrete
Gefährdung durch Islamisten in
Deutschland und sie betonte wir
beobachten das sehr genau mit Blick auf
den Nahen Osten sein alle
Sicherheitsbehörden alarmiert in
Duisburg hatte die Polizei gestern einen
mutmaßlichen islamistischen Gefährder
festgenommen heute wurde Haftbefehl
erlassen Peter Böhmer hat mehr ein
meerfamilienhaus in Duisburg gestern
Nachmittag hier wurde Tarik es
festgenommen gegen den 29-Jährigen wird
nun ermittelt nach Hinweisen auf
Anschlagspläne es haben sich
Erkenntnisse de gehend ergeben dass der
Beschuldigte mit einer Person im Ausland
in strafrechtlich relevanter Weise in
Kontakt gestanden haben könnte es
besteht der Verdacht
der Verabredung zu einem Verbrechen
konkret dass er sich gegebenenfalls
bereit erklärt haben könnte ein
Verbrechen zu begehen laut
Medienberichten könnte tark s geplant
haben mit einem Lastwagen in eine
proisraelische Demonstration zu fahren
der Mann in Ostwestfalen aufgewachsen
kämpfte für den islamischen Staat in
Syrien wurde verurteilt unter anderem
wegen Mitgliedschaft in einer
terroristischen Vereinigung saß nach
Jugendstrafrecht 5 Jahre in Haft der
Hinweis auf Tarek s kam von einem
ausländischen Nachrichtendienst die
Indizien gegen ihn haben sich offenbar
erhärtet die Polizei hat die Wohnung
unverzüglich durchsucht es konnten
Beweise wie unter anderem Datenträger
beschlagnahmt werden bei der ersten
Auswertung der Datenträger ergaben sich
weitere Anhaltspunkte die seine plne ver
schaulichten und den tatverdracht gegen
ihn
untermauern der Krieg im Nahen Osten
könnte nun die Anschlagsgefahr in Europa
erhöhen die Bedrohungslage ist deutlich
gestiegen wir haben eine unglaublich
polarisierte Atmosphäre emotional
angeheiz und es kann durchaus sein dass
der Konflikt im Nahen Osten so eine Art
Trigger war Tarek s soll laut seines
anwaldts im Islamismus
Aussteigerprogramm des Landes NRW
gewesen sein eine Bestätigung gibt es
dafür bisher nicht
wochenlang hatte Hamburg
proalästinensische Demonstrationen
untersagt jetzt fand zum ersten Mal eine
legale Kundgebung statt am frühen Abend
hatten sich mehrere hundert Menschen in
St Georg versammelt die Veranstaltung
lief unter strengen Auflagen verboten
waren transparente oder reden die das
Existenzrecht Israels in Frage stellen
oder Solidarität mit der Hamas
zeigen in die USA jetzt dort können seit
di Wochen keine Gesetze beschlossen
werden weil sich die Republikaner im
Repräsentantenhaus auf keinen Sprecher
einigen können Anfang Oktober wurde
Kevin McCarthy nach einem parteiinternen
Machtkampf als Vorsitzender abgewählt
seitdem scheiterten schon drei neue
Kandidaten denn der rechte Flügel der
Republikaner will keinen moderaten
Vorsitzenden die gemäßigten hingegen
wollen keinen Hardliner nun probiert es
Trump Unterstützer Mike Johnson Claudia
Bates hat
mehr die Abstimmung im
Repräsentantenhaus beginnt in diesen
Minuten ob der Kandidat Mike Johnson
seine Republikaner hinter sich
versammeln kann noch unklar Johnson ein
Trump loyalist der die wahllüge des
Ex-Präsidenten unterstützt die letzte
Präsidentschaftswahl im Parlament nicht
beurkunden wollte auf die Frage ob er
das Wahlergebnis kippen wollte nur
hämisches Lachen eine weitere Frage der
Reporterin wird von einer
republikanischen Abgeordneten mit sei
still hau ab quittit
Johnson beschwört die
Einheit Demokratie ist manchmal ein
Durcheinander aber es ist unser System
diese republikanische Fraktion ist
vereint dabei ist Johnson nun der vierte
Kandidat gestern noch wurde Tom Emmer
nominiert doch schon nach Stunden warf
er das Handtuch er hatte keine Chance
mehr auf eine Mehrheit seiner
Republikaner nachdem Donald Trump ihn
auf Social Media Angriff der
frolockt
ich muss da absolut einen Einfluss
gehabt haben denn sobald ich ihm die
Unterstützung entzog ich habe ihn nie
unterstützt ich wurde nie gut von ihm
behandelt er war kein Trump
[Musik]
Republikaner die Republikaner völlig
zerstritten zwischen moderaten und
trumpisten ein Ex-Präsident der weiter
die Fäden zieht und seinen Kandidaten
durchsetzen konnte neue Militärhilfen
für Israel und die Ukraine müssten
beschlossen werden viele im Kongress vor
allem die Demokraten hoffen dass dies
nun bald debattiert werden
kann zum Schiffsunglück in der Nordsee
nach dem Zusammenstoß zweier Frachter
zwischen langeog und Helgoland gibt es
keine Hoffnung mehr die vier Vermissten
lebend zu finden damit steigt die Zahl
der Toten Seeleute auf fünf nach wie vor
ist unklar warum die Schiffe kollidiert
sind morlin ilau
berichtet dieser 190 m lange Frachter
ist sicher in kuckshafen angekommen die
Spuren des z stoßes sichtbar die
Hamburger Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
zur Unfallursache das gesunkene Schiff
die Verity liegt in 34 mern Tiefe
Taucher wurden per Hubschrauber in die
raue See gelassen auf der Suche nach
Überlebenden ohne Erfolg und ohne
Hoffnung wie jetzt bestätigt wurde
weitere Tauchgänge von Tauchern sind
nicht möglich die Bedingungen lassen das
nicht zu und wir können wollen noch
keine Menschen diesem Risiko aussetzen W
in einem solchen Wrack bei den
Temperaturen über die Zeit
eingeschlossen ist hat ganz objektiv
gesehen keine Überlebenschance die am
Meeresgrund liegende varity hat etwa 127
Kubikmeter Marin diesiesel an Bord eine
geringe Menge ist schon ausgetreten
umweltschützer fordern dass jetzt rasch
gehandelt wird es gibt sicherlich
Möglichkeiten den Diesel auch in der
Wassertiefe abzupumpen durch eine
schlauchherstellung aber man kann das
Schiff auch garantiert an die Oberfläche
bringen und dann den Diesel Abpumpen es
sind bereits mehrere Spezialschiffe im
Einsatz an einem bergungsplan wird
gearbeitet der Unfallort ist eines der
meist befahrenen Seegebiete
weltweit und jetzt Fußball Champions
League pech für Berlin Glück für München
gestern Abend ja fangen wir mal mit den
Münchnern an die mussten nach Istanbul
in den berühmt berüchtigten Hexenkessel
des galatasari Stadions ein wilder Kick
lange Zeit auf Augenhöhe am Ende siegte
der FCB mit
3:1 ohrenbetäubendes Pfeifkonzert
während des gesamten Spiels gegen die
Bayern die gehen aber in der aten minute
durch Kingsley comman in Führung dann 30
Minute 11 m hochverdienter Ausgleich
durch Mauro incardi Istanbul führt den
FCB regelrecht vor 16:3 Torschüsse zur
Pause doch dann München eiskalt erst
Harry Kane in der 73 Minute und kurz
danach Jamal musjala zum 3 Z1
stand ja drei Spiele drei Siege für
München Spiele drei Niederlagen für die
Berliner Union verliert zu Hause 0:1
gegen SSC Neapel am Abend spielen noch
Leipzig und Dortmund die Höhepunkte
aller Spiele von gestern und heute bei
uns um 23 Uhr im Sportstudio Champions
League für die DFB Frauen und Interims
Coach Rube stehen jetzt zwei wichtige
nations League Spiele an Freitag gegen
Wales Dienstag gegen Island für Unruhe
sorgt ein Instagram Post der derzeit
pausierenden Bundestrainerin Martina v
steckelenburg
rund ums Team schwirren die Signale die
nach dem frühen WM aus im Sommer
kritisierte Bundestrainerin im
Erholungsurlaub signalisiert die Absicht
dass wir gemeinschaftlich einen Weg
finden wieder erfolgreich
zusammenzuarbeiten der DFB signalisiert
ein kommendes Gespräch Übergangstrainer
Host rubesch signalisiert bis Olympia
nächstes Jahr bleiben zu können alles in
allem eher Störsignale so kurz vor dem
nächsten Spiel ich persönlich kann sagen
dass es für uns gerade echt nicht das
relevanteste ist bzw wir gerade hier in
einer ja sehr fußballerisch ernsten
Situation sage ich mal stecken der DFB
kommuniziert mit seiner Bundestrainerin
nach eigenen Angaben momentan über
Anwälte das klingt nach einem
komplizierten
Verhältnis ja hoffentlich bringt das mal
keine Unruhe ins dfbteam stehen ja eben
gerade sehr wichtige Spiele an J danke
schön fehlt noch ein Stück
Musikgeschichte heute vor genau 40
Jahren spielte Udo Lindenberg sein
einziges DDR Konzert vor dem Mauerfall
im Palast der Republik in Ostberlin trat
Udo vor auserwähltem regimtreuem
Publikum auf eine komplette Tour durch
die DDR war den SED Bossen aber zu
heikel die hatten den Panikrocker
1983 erst nach langem Hin und Her
wiederwillig ins Land gelassen im selben
Jahr hatte Udo seine charmoffensive an
Erich honny honcker gestartet mit dem
Sonderzug nach Panko
chuldigen sie
ist das der S
nach ich muss mal eben
dahin mal eben nach Ostberlin ja fehlen
noch die Lottozahlen sie lauten
14 10 25
3149 und die Superzahl 7 weitere
Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zf.de und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 trüb und regnerisch geht der Oktober
weiter Details hat gleich Katja hornffer
Anne gellineek begrüßt sie um
uh im heute journal wir wünschen Ihnen
noch einen schönen Abend und sind morgen
wieder da auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen guten Abend das ist so ein
bisschen wie täglich grüß das Murmeltier
denn in lockerer Folge ziehen die tief
über Mitteleuropa hinweg gesteuert
werden sie durch dieses große tief über
dem Atlantik dass sich kaum von der
Stelle rührt so hat es heute kräftig
geregnet und es wird auch noch bis
morgen Abend weiter regnen besonders im
Schwarzwald erwarten uns Regenmengen von
70 l pro quadratmeer sie sehen durchaus
es gibt auch Regionen wo es nur ganz
wenig regnet der Regen der Nacht sieht
weiter nach Nordosten auch an den
alpenregn ist noch länger und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 11 bis 7° die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen
zwischen 11 und 16° dabei wird es am
oberrein am mildesten das wird morgen
ein trüber Tag am längsten regnetes wie
gesagt noch in der Südhälfte bei einem
recht kräftigen Wind aus südwestlichen
Richtungen Regenschauer gibt's aber auch
nordöstlich der Elbe Chancen auf Sonne
haben sie allenfalls im Norden
Schleswig-Holsteins und vielleicht
zwischen dem Sauerland und dem vogland
und wechselhaft geht es dann auch in den
nächsten Tagen weiter ab und zu könnte
auch mal ein einzelnes Gewitter dabei
sein und der Sonntag wird ausgesprochen
bei 13 bis 19° guten Abend